look we did the hot seat draft earlier
today
on pft live and you and i both
considered putting mike tomlin on the
hot seat
i can't imagine the steelers firing him
because they never fire anybody
especially coaches although
chuck noll was kind of nudged out after
you know all those years of greatness
but then there were some years of
relative mediocrity but i
look
it all comes down to dollars and cents
and if people start staying away from
those games and eventually people in
pittsburgh will they will only take so
much ineptitude before they say screw
this we'll go to penguins games instead
that's when you have to take it more
seriously you know the rooney's have
been able to stand behind chuck noll
bill cower and mike tomlin because far
more often than not the teams are good
they they were not like that pre-1969
because the teams weren't good they were
like every other team where you got to
fire somebody after every few years if
you stink so if the steelers are going
to stink this year and they're already
three games into stink
is mike tomlin vulnerable and i really
do think that there's a way the dominoes
fall where art rooney decides i got to
make a change chris yeah i mean i i get
it you know hey
you know that's the perception
perception's reality they're not playing
good they didn't go to the playoffs last
year you know the antonio brown saga
mike tomlin is a defensive coach their
defense is 28th in football you know
it's mike thomas the winningest coach
ever in the history of the pittsburgh
steelers he's been to two super bowls
won one of them there's a lot of great
uh but yeah it's not looking good right
now i don't expect it to be an in-season
change i don't think that's like the dna
of the pittsburgh steelers i agree i
agree yeah i'm kind of with you i think
it'll be something they do after the
season's over but yeah things continue
this way
uh it's hard it's hard not to say that
he wouldn't be on the hot seat and that
they wouldn't consider a change just the
way things have gone down the last few
years now i'll say this for some reason
mike tomlin gets blamed for the le'veon
bell situation which i think we both
agree come on that was just business of
the nfl and le'veon bell had the guts to
basically play hardball and he did that
that had nothing to do with mike tomlin
and managing the football team and i
think the other thing where we can
defend mike tomlin a little bit and i
know okay he's partly to blame too
but damn i think we've learned he did a
lot of good managing dan antonio brown i
mean it was he did some miracle work did
he though well he might have he might
have he might have like helped you know
bring along he created
a little
i he created the monster but he's still
within that monster went like seven or
eight years of handling that monster
until the end of last year where really
financial components got into this and
antonio brown and that's why he wanted
out of there so uh you know we're seeing
the raiders the patriots antonio brown
wasn't that easy to handle all together
with all the things that goes on
and maybe maybe the monster had to be
created otherwise it had to be killed
right i mean maybe mike tomlin didn't
enable him
it all would have fallen apart and they
wouldn't have the benefit of a of a very
talented antonio brown and he would have
been out of the league
exactly maybe this meltdown would have
happened in 2012 right so
he he did he did
create a set of rules for antonio brown
and look the other way on some things
but maybe he knew in his heart he had to
because this is one guy you can't push
even though he's a six round pick
because i've said before look at some
point between being a sixth round pick
from central michigan and becoming the
best receiver in the nfl there's a way
to clip his wings and keep him from
becoming a diva maybe mike tomlin knew
there was no way he was going to stop it
from happening and it was just going to
all fall apart didn't accommodate
antonio brown i got to give him some
credit yeah yeah i'll give him a little
credit yeah good for you that's all
right that's easy i think he does
deserve i mean listen i mean if bill
belichick and bill parcells drew a hard
line with lawrence taylor i don't think
things would have worked out real well i
think there's a number of relationships
we could have gone through in the
history of football where we go man if
they really drew a hard line and try to
clip the wings as you say uh that that
could have just fallen apart we never
would have saw that star really flourish
and i think there's a number of examples
and it's part of football and what
happens sometimes
some of you may be saying well wait a
minute how can mike tomlin be on the hot
seat didn't he get an extension in the
offseason but remember and when we when
we were able to kind of scratch the
surface a little bit it is ultimately a
one-year bump yeah and it's not nearly
the kind of financial commitment that
would keep the steelers from making a
move if they believe their broader
business interests necessitate making a
change and i know from being 100 miles
away from pittsburgh any time that team
struggles on mike tomlin's watch you
have people in pittsburgh who want to
get rid of him yeah and if they are 0
and 4 0 and 5 0 and 6
1 and 8 2 and 10 that's not acceptable
based upon the standard they've set in
pittsburgh and that's the kind of thing
that can get people overwhelmingly in
support of making a coaching change and
if it ever becomes a serious financial
issue for the steelers then i think they
have no choice but to move on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports